the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so I am super excited about
today because this is in my opinion the
highest point of the apex of the course
well we're gonna put together everything
you've done so far and start to explain
things like bremsstrahlung radiation
damage x-ray spectra that you get in a
scanning electron microscope and
actually find a way where cross-sections
are areas where remember before I told
you guys cross-sections measured in
barns in centimeters squared think of it
kind of like an area I'll actually be
able to show mathematically that some of
them do derive from actual areas so it
will make a lot more sense it's not just
an abstract concept what I want to do is
a quick review of the ionization and
excitation collisions that we did last
time remember we had this imaginary
hollow cylinder where we've said that
there's some ion traveling in this
direction with charge let's say Z times
the electron charge and it's colliding
kind of with an electron somewhere else
separated by some impact parameter V B
and let's say this hollow cylinder had a
shell of thickness DB and we started off
with this situation where we wanted to
say we can find the Y momentum is the
integral of the Y force we did something
and one of the intermediate steps we
came up with was that our energy and
part of the electron is P squared over
two times mass of the electron which
came out to 2z squared e to the fourth
over mass the electron impact parameter
squared velocity squared then we
multiplied by the electron density and
the material which was the number
density of atoms times Z the number of
electrons per atom times the area the
cross-sectional area of this hollow
cylindrical shell which came out to two
pi B which is the circumference of that
circle right there times DB
DX I'm just gonna leave that there for
now and we'll come back to it in a sec I
will mention though that at the end we
came up with our stopping power
expression let's call this ionizations
that came out to 4pi this constant K
naught squared which comes from the
Coulomb force law little Z squared big z
e to the fourth over mass of the
electron velocity squared writing out of
rhythm times log of mass the electron V
squared over this mean this mean
excitation energy which comes out to
around let's say 10 to 19 electron volts
times Z and what this meant was that if
we graph stopping power as a function of
energy there's a couple components to it
one of them is this roughly 1 over
energy component so let's say there's a
component of it yes I love when I can do
that that actually that follows kind of
1 over e and there's this logarithmic
component that kind of goes like that
way and if we sum them together we ended
up with a much higher stopping power low
energies but around this local minimum
of about 3 times mass of the electrons C
squared it starts to increase again and
that's due to this
how many excitation can you make as a
function of energy so if you think about
it this is kind of like a an energy term
how much energy do you have divided by
how many ionizations can you make so
it's kind of an intuitive result in that
it's how much energy you've got versus
how much energy it takes for a single
unit process and that's all mediated by
this 1 over e term the last thing that
we said is that this curves back down
here and that's because
and around 500 times this mean
excitation energy which as you can see
is around you know 1 ke V times e it's
not a very high energy you start to get
charged neutralization the reason for
that is that for an order for this
formula to work we have to assume that
the deflection is really really really
small infant estimate Li small if it's
not and if the ion manages to catch that
electron it's not going to it's not
going to lose energy by you know
undergoing a Coulomb interaction it's
going to lose energy by absorbing that
electron and neutralizing and so for
really low energy the ions are moving so
slowly that they can capture some of
those electrons and it gets less and
less effective at stopping the material
and this led to let's see this word
distance and this were DT DX times the
energy required to make an ion pair
which we'll just call this I we ended up
with a curve that looked something like
this where this right here we call the
range it just gave that the symbol R so
that's the review of last time but I
left some extra space for some reasons
which will become clear in about half an
hour right now I want to take you
through a little bit of a whirlwind in
terms of bremsstrahlung I'm not going to
derive anything about it we're just
going to go over what the cross-sections
and stopping powers look like why they
take that form intuitively but we're not
going to go through a rigorous
derivation because well simply don't
have time but I do want you to know what
sort of things exist
so for bremsstrahlung better known as
braking radiation
who's actually heard of this before does
anyone know roughly let's say if we were
to say some cross section for
bremsstrahlung let's call it cross
section radiative because in this case
we're actually talking about the charged
particle radiating away photon so let's
say we had some nucleus of charge big Z
and we had some ion we'll give it a
different color some ion of charge
little Z moving towards it it'll either
be attracted or repelled depending on
what the sign looks like and sometimes
you might get radiation of a photon
let's call it of energy e equals HC over
lambda that'll become important in a sec
so this radiative cross section I don't
care about particularly care about the
exact form but what is it proportional
to what sort of factors do you think
would make the emission of that photon
more or less likely yeah sure the energy
of the charged particle so you can
there's there's one expression I like
you can only take my money until you
take it all well the same thing goes for
the energy of a photon you can't can't
radiate any more than the energy of the
particle coming in so there's going to
be some maximum energy which is going to
correspond to some minimum wavelength
which is let's say if we just put our
initial energy in here that gives us our
minimum wavelength right there that's
true and it can radiate at any energy
smaller than that or any wavelength
larger than that I'm basically saying
the same thing because if this particle
started off further away and felt less
of a deflection it could still emit a
photon but of a longer wavelength don't
have room to draw enough wavelengths but
I want to make sure that's physically
accurate
so it's actually going to be also
proportional to Z of the large nucleus
the stronger the pull the more of that
breaking radiation you're going to see
it's actually proportional to Z squared
what this says is that heavier Z
materials produce a lot more of this
breaking radiation and it's also
proportional to the inverse of the mass
squared and what this says intuitively
is a heavier particle deflects less and
emits less of this breaking radiation
hopefully this makes a lot of sense to
you guys that the stronger the pull of
the nucleus the more deflection you're
going to get and the more bremsstrahlung
you'll get the larger the mass of the
incoming ion let's say that's mass M the
less deflection you'll get because the
less what is it the less momentum
transfer you can apply with the same
force if you've got a lot happier
particle this makes sense to everybody
so what this says is it's really
important for high Z materials and we'll
see a little bit why if I actually write
the full expression for stopping power
and I promised you I'm not gonna derive
it so we don't really have the time for
that it's proportional to the number
density you should always think there'll
be a number density in stopping power
because the more atoms there are the
more they stop things
it's just directly proportional times
that kinetic energy plus M EC squared
and again this is not something I want
you to memorize but it is something I
want you to be able to decompose and
explain why the parts are there let's
see times some radiative cross-section
where this sigma radiative
is some constant cross-section this ends
up being about 1 over 500 barns times Z
squared times this parameter B which if
you see in the reading is actually given
just this B scales roughly with the
atomic with I'm sorry with yeah with the
proton number of the material so you can
see that in here in the stopping power
is actually directly the cross section
so the components of a stopping power
there's going to be some probability of
interaction and there's going to be some
energy transfer part this is a kind of
interesting result to show this is why I
wanted to just write the bremsstrahlung
stopping power because in here actually
is the croc session time some other
stuff pretty neat result and so now I
want to show you how our cross section
is actually contained in the ionization
stopping power so let's bring this back
down for a second you can think of the
likelihood that the ion comes off with
any particular energy to be directly
related to this impact parameter because
as we saw the final expression for
stopping power is directly related to
this parameter B we ended up integrating
over all possible B to get the total
stopping power in the material but if we
didn't do that integral if we stopped
let's say at this stage in the game and
we said all right we'll the stopping
power at some fixed B actually depends
on the probability that that particle
enters into this cross sectional area
right here this 2 pi B DB that right
there is the cross section for
scattering as a function of the incoming
energy and the outgoing energy this is
one of the coolest parts I think is that
there's an actual area right here it's
the area of a hollow circle is the
actual cross
action for scattering with a given
ingoing and outgoing outcoming energy
and then the rest of this stuff if you
pull all this together if you take a
microscopic cross-section times the
number of particles that are there
because this is your atomic number
density and these two together are your
electron number density like we talked
about before with reaction rates and
cross-sections this thing right here is
your macroscopic cross-section for an
incoming and an outgoing energy
contained directly in the stopping power
formula because then we integrated over
all possible cross-sections which means
all possible outgoing energies for a
given incoming energy and so the last
bit the way to link these two together
which is why I left a little bit of
space right here we know right now
because I wrote it up there that the
scattering cross-section is a function
of the ingoing and outgoing energy per
unit energy is just the area of that
hollow circle so let's divide everything
by DT we end up with the total formula
for cross for the scattering
cross-section we don't know what this B
DB DT is like what's the what's the
differential probability between impact
parameter and outgoing energy we don't
quite know but we can express this as a
change of variables that we do know we
do know if you we have a certain impact
parameter we know what the scattering
angle is going to be there's a
well-known relation for that and there's
a derivation in the book and in another
book that I want to point out to you
guys by Gary wasp called fundamentals of
radiation material science
on page 32 if anyone wants to see the
derivation from which this result was
came this came from you can head right
there and it's free on MIT libraries
meanwhile we do know a relation between
this impact parameter and the angle and
we do know a relation between this angle
and the outgoing energy and this is
where some of the hard sphere collision
stuff comes in what's the maximum amount
of energy that a particle can impart to
another particle in some sort of a hard
sphere like collision let's take the
easy example if the two particles have
equal mass how much energy can one
particle in part to another all of it
right can impart a maximum of let's say
this incoming energy E I as those mass
ratios change you can impart a maximum
let's say your maximum becomes what's
called gamma e I where this gamma right
here is four times those two masses
multiplied over the sum squared the full
expression I'm going to use a different
color because I'm running out of space
here the full expression for T is
actually gamma e I over 2 times 1 minus
cosine theta the two intuitive limits
from this is if theta equals PI then
this here equals 2 and T is our T
maximum just gamma times e aí if theta
equals zero that whole thing equals zero
and in our case of forward scattering no
interaction occurs and the energy
imparted is zero but the important part
here is we have a direct relation
between T and theta and the angle which
we can put in here and we actually have
a direct relation between B and theta
which I wrote down so I wouldn't forget
so we actually have our impact parameter
is classical radius of the electron
times cosine of angle over two you don't
have to know where these came from but
the point is we have a relation between
B and the angle we have a relation
between angle and energy so we can just
do a change of variables to get our
final cross-section and it ends up being
think pi times radius of the electrons
squared over gamma e I so in this way we
can go from known relations between each
of the variables and an actual physical
cross-section that has units of real
area down to an energy dependent form
for this cross-section which i think is
pretty cool and then this is the one
that you would see tabulated in the
janice tables like the energy dependent
cross section for the s reaction or
scattering so this is one of my favorite
parts of this course because you can see
how cross-sections really do follow
directly from areas so now for the other
part now that we've got this
bremsstrahlung stopping power and we've
got our ionization stopping power it's
useful to find out which one is more
important when to do that we just look
at their ratios so if we look at the DT
DX from ionizations over the DT DX from
radiative energy transfer or
bremsstrahlung I want to make sure I get
this one right it's proportional to Z
times mass of the electron over m
squared times T over 14-hundred rest
mass of the electron so what this tells
you here is that I'm sorry I think I
have those backwards because radiative
should get more important at higher
energies
so what this tells you is for hires
e-materials bremsstrahlung becomes more
dominant and for higher energies
bremsstrahlung becomes more dominant so
if we want to generalize our stopping
power curve from just ionization to
everything that's why I know I had
another color no I ran out of colors
I need a fourth one there's gonna be
some bremsstrahlung component that
starts to get more and more important
with increasing energy and so then if
you extend this curve
you're gonna radiate more and more and
more power the higher energy you go not
from this component or that component of
ionization but from radiation or Bream
strollin so this has some pretty serious
implications to answer questions like
how do you shield beta rays anyone have
any idea based on this formula right
here what would you use to shield beta
particles and not radiate the person
standing behind the shield well let's
ask the question everyone knows what are
you used to shield photons really well
LED tungsten something with high Z
because as we saw from before I'm gonna
steal a little bit of the radiate the
Rutherford stuff if you graph the energy
versus the mass attenuation coefficient
you get a curve that looks like this but
everything increases with increasing Z
you get more mass attenuation with
increasing Z and also denser materials
tend to be higher Z is that what you
want to do for beta particles you say so
Monica you say no how come
that's right well you don't necessarily
want something with a low cross-section
or else it might not shield it all but
you are on the right track you can
actually look at the difference between
these stopping powers and cross-sections
are embedded in there so I think that
answer is pretty much correct but also
you're going to get more bremsstrahlung
or more breaking radiation in higher Z
materials so if we actually look at at
what thresholds does this become
important in lead this ratio is about
one at around 10 MeV which means that
you lose an equal amount of energy to
bremsstrahlung as ionization at 10 MeV
for electrons in water this ratio is
about one at a hundred MeV so what this
says is if you want to shield electrons
or beta particles safely you actually
have to use lower Z materials because
they won't make much bremsstrahlung but
because like Monica said then the
cross-section is lower you actually have
to use more so you don't have a choice
you can't just use less high Z material
because while you will stop more of the
electrons they will create more x rays
in the process and those x rays are
highly penetrating as we know from these
mass attenuation curves once you get to
high energy this is all these are
logarithmic scale so let me correct
those and say these are log of e and log
of mu over p it gets millions of times
less effective at shielding high energy
photons so that's one of those really
important things to note is if you're
designing shielding for something and
there are electrons involved that are
even around 1 MeV or so you can't just
use high Z materials to shield them or
you will create more problems than you
solve that's a pretty important
implication it's quite important for
what's called beta voltaic devices it's
kind of a sidetrack so I'm gonna stick
it on a board that'll be hidden soon so
anyone heard of a beta voltaic device
anyone what are they
yeah it's a beta battery all it is is
let's say some pieces of silicon some
circuit that grabs the power and a beta
emitter and these beta particles
directly hit the silicon and the
movement of those betas constitutes a
charge and it's direct Korea it's direct
conversion of radiation to electrical
energy they're not very high power but
they last for a very long time how long
around a few half-lives of that beta
decay so for most of these beta emitters
that have half-lives in the realm of
like 10 to a thousand years you can make
a microwatt battery that could last for
millennia
this could be pretty useful let's say if
you wanted to have some secret sensors
in a naughty country like North Korea
you could drop these tiny little beta
particles that would just bethe voltaic
s--
that would just trickle charge a battery
make a measurement of I don't know
radiation level or weight of the
dictator or whatever you happen to want
to measure and send that off once a
month or once a year with no need for
external monitoring or let's say you're
designing a comet a mission to land on a
comet like the Rosetta feel a lander and
your radio thermal isotope generator is
going to burn out and let's say 10 or 20
years you might not need that much power
just to measure temperature or light
levels or something else or a gas that
you might want to know what's there but
you have to choose your beta isotope
wisely if you want to make these things
in a little chip and they actually have
been commercialized in a chip that's
about that actual size using about two
Curie's of tritium anyone have any idea
why one would choose tritium yep
it's got us yep it's got a short
half-life so you can get a lot of power
out of it that's that's one of the two
correct reasons and what is the other
one that lets see who's memorized their
Kyrie table of nuclides what do you
think it's beta decay energy would have
to be for this not to blast anyone in
the vicinity very low why do you say
that that's true their range is much
smaller but the range of all betas is
pretty low in materials but the answer
lies right here less bremsstrahlung
lower energy betas give most of their
energy off in ionization rather than by
radiating bremsstrahlung so you can have
a device with two Curie's of tritium
which if that's released to the outside
world that's bad news that's something
that you might have to report but as
long as it stays contained in this
device it does not have enough energy to
produce many x-rays from bremsstrahlung
and therefore it does not require an
enormous amount of shielding so you
can't just pick a one MeV beta emitter
which you might get a lot of power out
of because it's also going to be a big
crazy x-ray source that you wouldn't
want in a cellphone or a sensor or some
other device you might put in your
pocket or even like 20 feet from you
cool so that's the idea behind
bremsstrahlung there's a little bit more
I want to tell you about it and I'll
save that for the side track board we
use bremsstrahlung in a lot of really
interesting applications including
cyclotron one of which we just took
delivery of here at MIT or a synchrotron
and I'll just briefly explain how these
work in a cyclotron you've got two djp
magnets they actually call them DS
because we're so creative in naming
these things you inject some source of
charged particles and there's some
electric field lines across these 2d
magnets and what this says is that in
between the magnets the particle
accelerates and inside each magnet the
path curves and accelerates some more
and it's moving even faster so it takes
longer to curve then it moves even
faster and it takes longer to curve and
so on and so on until it finally shoots
out the side and so this is one way that
you can have an extremely compact and
I'm talking like garbage cans sized
accelerator that brings things up to
about 13 MeV that's the one that we've
got in the basement of Northwest 13 the
problem is every time these particles
Bend they send off photons what's known
as cyclotron radiation and the more the
higher energy that is the more intense
that cyclotron radiation gets so you've
got this garbage can sized device with a
little hole right here and it's just
blasting out photons in all directions
in this one plane let's just call it the
plane of death what you don't want to be
in which is why this thing is behind
four feet of concrete shielding and in
the middle of a room to help you know
that one over R squared keeps your dose
down but we actually use this plane of
death in a synchrotron what it is is
it's a circular accelerator it's not
quite circular so let me correct my
drawing a little bit there are straight
segments and there are slightly curved
segments but it pretty much looks like a
circle if you look at it from high up
enough in each of these curved segments
there is a bending magnet it's my best
drawing for a magnet and what this does
is it continuously changes the path of
these charged particles going through
usually electrons and you end up with
intense beams we use a different color
you end up with intense beams
perpendicular to the original path
before it went in that bending magnet of
synchrotron radiation so it's kind of
like a Giga electron volts spinning
ninja star of death except at the end of
every one of these stations you have
what's called a beam line because
there's 60 or 80 odd of these beam lines
coming off with let's say 80 kV and
below
brem stellar x-rays you can use those
for a whole lot of different analysis
techniques you can simply irradiated
end those x-rays through a monochromator
to select only one wavelength and then
use that wavelength to probe the
structure of matter down to the atomic
level there's actually one of these just
down in Long Island about a two and a
half hour drive from here there's
Brookhaven National Lab and they just
opened up the National synchrotron light
source or NSLs version to where they can
actually measure distances with sub nan
at single nanometre precision so inside
this beam line is a bigger room which is
encased in another room which is encased
in another room and the whole point of
that is for vibration and temperature
isolation so they maintain this entire
room to within a spec of 0.1 Celsius and
it's like the least vibrating place
probably in the u.s. I don't know about
on the planet but it's got basically no
vibration so the atoms are effectively
standing still except for their normal
vibrations in the material but there's
no source of external vibration and the
cooling has to come in through these
convoluted channels so as not to blow on
the sample so it's not to make any
convection currents or temperature
changes and they can actually probe the
structure of matter with single
nanometre precision using these
synchrotron x-rays all produced by
bremsstrahlung so it's not all bad you
can use bremsstrahlung for good then
there's a little bit I have to hijack a
little more area from Rutherford
scattering you might think about well
what is the actual spectrum of this
bremsstrahlung well you can look to see
what's the probability that an atom
enters into any of these concentric
hollow circles it looks to be less and
less likely that you're going to enter
through one of the center rings more and
more likely that you're going to enter
through one of the outer rings if you
start farther away there's less of a
pull to change the path of that ion or
electron and the bremsstrahlung is going
to be lower in energy this is actually
described by what's called Kramer's law
which says that the intensity of the
bremsstrahlung is a function of
wavelength scales with some constant K
and that constants scales with
surprise-surprise the atomic number of
the material times some lambda over
lambda minimum minus 1 times 1 over
lambda squared and what this says is
that there's some minimum lambda or some
maximum energy that you can impart to
this bremsstrahlung which again you can
only take some energy before you take it
all and there's going to be some sort of
a fixed minimum lambda if we draw this
intensity and I graph this on desmos
just before coming here so I know it
looks something like this where that
right there is lambda minimum it's
taking more area if you then change
variables from lambda to the angular
frequency where if you remember the
energy of the photon is just h-bar times
that frequency so it's kind of like
converting into energy with just a tiny
little constant in front and I mean
really really tiny little constant you
end up with an energy relation that
looks like some maximum angular
frequency or some maximum energy this is
kind of simple linear ish look in
relation this one over energy relation
minus 1 so if we graph energy
is the intensity of the bremsstrahlung
you end up with a curve something like
this where your max energy is the same
as your incoming particle energy now who
here has done any sort of x-ray or SEM
analysis before you have so can you tell
me is this the bremsstrahlung spectrum
that you tend to see okay have you ever
gotten a regular old x-ray spectrum to
see what elements are there can you draw
what one looks like I'm gonna try
they're all the same so if you remember
any particular one you're correct
yep there's some Peaks and then what
does this background stuff look like
yeah there's some noise and junk on the
back of it right so I'm that this is
actually correct thank you
and what you actually see here is a
bunch of characteristic Peaks these will
maybe be like the L lines and the K
lines for one element or the other these
characteristic x-ray Peaks on top of the
bremsstrahlung
the breaking radiation which constitutes
the background here and what you
actually see I'm just gonna draw the
background curve under julia's curve
here look something like this what
happened to the real spectrum
why don't we observe what actually
exists there are a couple of reasons
does anybody have an idea
so why let's take this to the extreme
why don't you think you would observe
physically and this is when we actually
get into the real world any x-rays with
energy in the let's say the evey range
if you were to try and observe any
x-rays at all this is where we actually
get into what do these detectors look
like so there'll be some active piece of
your material if this is your detector
this is most definitely not Rutherford
scattering anymore and there's got to be
some window we can make it as thin as we
possibly can and they make it out of the
most x-ray transparent structural
material that they can which tends to be
beryllium so beryllium it's got an
atomic number four it's the first and
lightest element that you can make
structural anything's out of so if you
want to protect your detector from let's
say air or something that if this were
full of air it would absorb the x-rays
so you want there to be pretty much
nothing you can put a very thin like
seven micron beryllium window in front
but the problem is we've already got one
of these mass attenuation curves and
when you get down to these energy levels
you attenuate everything so the lower
energy your bremsstrahlung is the less
likely you're going to see it so even
though this is the actual bremsstrahlung
spectrum right this is what we observe
and I haven't finished grading the test
yet but like I promised for the two
folks who do the best I'm going to ask
you to bring something in for elemental
analysis this is precisely what we're
going to see you're going to see this
bremsstrahlung which is not the actual
spectrum coming out but this has to do
with the absorption of x-rays in the
detector window as well as some self
shielding if we're using a scanning
electron microscope which is
nothing more than an electron gun and
you're firing electrons to some distance
in the material where they'll then
interact and send off x-rays you've also
got this part of the material to contend
with some shell self shielding so not
only did the x-rays all have to get
through the detector window to be
counted so the high-energy ones which
we'll have with small wavelength get
through but the low energy or long
wavelength ones might get stopped you
also have to get out of the material
itself the electrons don't just produce
x-rays in the outer atoms of the
material they go down a micron or two
and then the x-rays that are produced in
those interactions have to get back out
again
so it's interesting it's kind of like
the inverse photoelectric effect right
and the photoelectric effect photon
comes in electrons come out in a
scanning electron microscope electrons
come in photons come out many of them
are these characteristic x-rays because
now if you start to review what sort of
interactions are possible when we fire
electrons into material we've just gone
over bremsstrahlung and we know that
with higher and higher energy electrons
you're gonna get more and more
bremsstrahlung but you're not going to
see the actual x-rays produced at low
energies no matter what because this
isn't just a system on paper it's real
life and you're going to get
characteristic x-rays that come from
energy transitions so if you fire in an
electron and you happen to undergo one
of these ionization collisions you might
just knock an electron out so let's say
an electron comes in knocks an electron
out then another electron fills that
shell giving off in this case it would
be a K alpha or a shell 2 - a shell 1
x-ray the way I've drawn it which is why
Julia's got everything right on this
spectrum here there's the bremsstrahlung
and then there's these characteristic
Peaks the background is due to radiative
stopping power
and these characteristic Peaks give away
some of the ionization stopping power
and so all in one spectrum you can see
just about everything going on in this
material the last thing that you can't
see but I would be remiss if I didn't
talk about it as a radiation material
scientist is radiation material science
which really is concerned with mostly
Rutherford scattering Rutherford or hard
sphere scattering this is the last of
the major interactions between charged
particles and matter that concern us
it's not really in your reading except
for I think being mentioned once because
they didn't seem to think it's important
but I happen to think it's extremely
important because this is the basis
behind radiation damage in all of these
collisions right here you have some sort
of displacement of electrons and those
electrons can get ionized and other ones
will fill them back in the holes and
whatever they'll do but at no point were
nuclei displaced you can transfer a lot
of energy without moving any atoms
around but when your energy starts to
get lower you end up with a new kind of
stopping power let's call it nuclear
which scales with as always a number
density times pi let's see little Z big
z e to the fourth everything looks
pretty similar so far except for now
we've got the energy of the incoming
material and now we have a mass ratio
because in this case you're actually
undergoing some sort of a hard sphere
collision between one atom and the other
times the natural log this is going to
look awfully familiar it ends up being
some energy term over actually let's
just go with yeah
gamma II I over some new energy this
thing right here is called the
displacement threshold energy and it
ranges from about 25 to 90 evey but it's
usually 40 evey and what that is it's
it's the max the minimum amount of
energy that has to be imparted to a
nucleus smack head on in order for it to
move from its original atomic position
and that's what's known as a hard sphere
type collision or in this case it's just
like all the other Q equation looking
scenarios that we looked at before right
so let's say the little nucleus goes off
and the big nucleus goes off this should
look familiar by now because I've harped
on it probably too much now what I want
you to consider is this big nucleus had
a position it liked where it was and now
it's been knocked away what's left over
is an atomic vacancy which is the most
basic building block of radiation damage
so sometimes it's neat to look at the
ratio of C make sure I get this ratio
right ionization on top to look and see
when is ionization versus radiation
damage actually important and the ratio
scales with two times the mass of the
nucleus over m easy times their
respective natural log threshold things
and that's the ionization potential and
log gamma AI over IDI so what this says
is that for higher energies ionization
is more important and for lower energies
nuclear stopping power of radiation
damage is more important if we graph
these two let's say on a log e ground
and let's say we have our nuclear
stopping power in blue and our
ionization stopping power in green we
end up with curves that look something
like this that's our nuclear that's our
electronic or ionic so what this
actually says is if you fire high-energy
neutrons or high-energy protons into a
material its ionization that does most
of the damage at high energies until you
slow down to around like the ten to a
hundred ke V level
curiously very similar to this 500 times
I bar the mean ionization potential at
which point Rutherford scattering or
hard sphere scattering becomes the
dominant mechanism and so what this says
is if we want to draw a picture of what
radiation damage looks like let's say we
had a proton that we're firing into a
material and it hits some atom that
we're gonna call the pKa or primary
knock on atom that PKA then becomes
let's say it was nickel it's like a
nickel plus 26 iron because you've
knocked the nucleus out of its electron
cloud effectively and it's now flying
out through the material that proton
might go off to do more damage somewhere
else but it's not actually the protons
of the incoming particles that do the
bulk of the final radiation damage
radiation damage is mostly self ion
irradiation even though it all starts
with the incoming particle nothing would
happen if the incoming particle didn't
show up most of the final results of the
damage are from these heavy ion
collisions and so we actually talked a
little a bit about I think we talked
about when this ionization starts to
pick up for electrons versus heavy ions
if you think about when electrons start
to radiate away most of their energy
taking it away from radiation it's like
10 to 100
mev what would be the case for a heavy
ion like even a proton well what's the
only thing that changed that changes
when you change from an electron to a
proton here let's James will say oh yeah
the charge is an opposite sign but of
equal strength but what else in this
formula that's right
so for heavy ions for even things like
protons you need to go at approximately
1837 squared
more energy than the electron so we're
talking in like the Giga electron volt
to tera electron volt range for ions so
this is why bremsstrahlung is not
important for any sort of ion
interactions unless you are a
high-energy physicist and you're working
in the GeV or Giga electron volt and up
range so we like to say in the radiation
damage field if you want to know the
total stopping power from all
interactions you have to take into
account the ionizations I'll just make
that a minus sign for the symbols the
nuclear and the radiative for most
radiation damage processes except for
high-energy electron radiation we
neglect that the reason is that the
radiative to ionization stopping power
is pretty close to zero it's like even
at 10 MeV it's like 1 over 2000 squared
or 1 over I guess 4 million doesn't
matter at all with heavier ions it
becomes even less of an issue because
you can deflect a heavier ion less with
the same Coulomb force and so what ends
up only mattering is the ionization
stopping power and the nuclear stopping
power it's this nuclear stopping power
that leads to collisions and it's like
two of five of so I want to stop here
and answer any questions and I'll hijack
a bit of the neutron discussion on
Thursday with some review of this and
filling in the last gaps of radiation
damage so anyone have any questions from
today yeah yep
the radiation term goes away because of
that yep if if you're working with an
electron then it actually does matter
like if you're firing 10 MeV electrons
into something you must account for the
radiative stopping power because there's
a lot of it at 10 MeV there's as much
radiative as ionizing and there's
basically no nuclear yet but for
anything heavier even muons which are
like approximately 237 times heavier or
protons which are approximately 1837
times heavier it totally doesn't matter
because it scales with the mass ratio
squared might be 267 for muons I forget
that middle number but still 267 squared
is a pretty big number was there another
question here thought I had seen a hand
so I remember you guys had said you want
to see some radiation material science
of radiation damage this is where it
comes from this is why I love teaching
graduate radiation damage and 2201 at
the same time because they're the same
thing
except you guys get the derivations and
in the grad class I say I assume they
know it and then in the homework I find
out they don't but it doesn't matter
because they're supposed to at least you
guys will so you've got the power and
knowledge brings fears I like to say
okay I'll see you guys on Thursday when
we'll wrap up a little bit more
radiation damage because I can't resist
and then we'll start moving into Neutron
interactions which is kind of taking a
step down from here because there aren't
really any electronic interactions but
because we can deal with enormous
populations of neutrons things are going
to get messy
seeing the equations shirts that we have
here the neutron transport equation
shirts yeah we're gonna derive that
Thursday